we want to have a good and happy and
fulfilling and comfortable life for
everybody on earth that requires certain
level living standards which we have in
historically relied on fossil fuels and
the use of the land to achieve but now
we're recognizing that the way we've
done that in the past is ultimately not
sustainable in the long term but at the
same time you can't rip that away
immediately because we rely on it so
much
i wanted to try and have a conversation
with you to work out how there is so
much disagreement about climate science
just people are prepared to accept it
eating too much makes you fat well not
everyone but most people that are saying
do smoking causes cancer but climate
science seems to probably be one of the
most contested
areas that i've seen
so for the people that aren't familiar
with you and your background what are
your credentials and what do you do
so i'm a climate scientist at the met
office which is the uk's national
weather service and climate service and
i'm also a professor at the university
of exeter
so i train as a physicist
i have a masters in meteorology and a
phd in meteorology
and i've worked in the met office's
climate research department the hadley
center for nearly nearly 30 years so
i've been working on the climate
modeling and then bringing in
observations and
these days applying it to risk
assessments to to
understand what we might have to do in
response to climate change
and the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change what is the role of that what's
the duty of that
so uh yes i'm a lead author on one of
the well several of the reports by the
uh intergovernment of paddle and climate
change the ipcc the role of that uh is
to
uh
produce authoritative assessments of the
science of climate change in many
different aspects so the
physical science understanding the
changes that are occurring what we're
expecting for the future but also the
the implications for human impacts uh
biodiversity impacts and so on and
um
and the uh
perhaps more challenge even more
challenging than all that the different
options um for reducing climate change
in terms of mitigation
uh the ipcc is uh is somewhat unique and
it also links very closely to
uh to government it's not a government
document but it is designed to inform
government policy so part of the process
at the end is to work very closely with
representatives of the world's
governments uh
to
to make sure that they are brought into
the uh the the the science of it and
that's where it gets particularly
interesting at the end at the end of the
process but it is a scientific document
ultimately
talk to me about this tension that i
brought up earlier on then why is it the
case that there can be so much
contested about something that to me
sounds like a science
so i think what is more contesting is
actually
what the responses are and what was what
this science is
taken to imply rather than the science
itself i mean with any science that
there's in always uh
somewhat different views uh you can
interpret
things in somewhat
different ways especially when it's a
big and complicated subject
but there's very few people if any that
can test the basic fundamental
science of
climate change in terms of greenhouse
gases exist carbon dioxide is a
greenhouse gas greenhouse gases keep the
earth warmer than it would have been
there's other gases like methane water
vapor they're also greenhouse gases
hardly anybody disputes that
where the controversy comes in some of
it is in terms of what we are expecting
for the future in terms of how severe
the future impacts will be if we keep
building up more greenhouse gases into
the in the atmosphere particularly
carbon dioxide there's a wide range of
possible outcomes of that so people tend
to focus on either the worst case or the
best case scenarios but even beyond that
there's uh the deepest controversies
about what this really means how urgent
it is to to reduce uh emissions should
we just live with the changes that we've
put into place how severe will those be
so when you get further down that chain
the real controversies come in i think
um how accurate are the
climate models now because even i know
that the weather guys get it wrong
sometimes and if they can't predict
what newcastle or austin texas is going
to see tomorrow whether it's going to
rain or not i imagine that all of the
complexities rolled forward over 10
years globally must be kind of difficult
yeah so we're working in the met office
obviously the main
a main role of the met up is to do the
weather forecast day to day and week
week by week and so on uh
and yes you can't always predict a few
days ahead exactly what's going to
happen we are actually pretty good now
with it within a few days perhaps even a
week ahead in some cases but it yeah the
atmosphere is very complex so
you're trying to predict individual
weather day-to-day and hour to hour you
can't do that more than a few days ahead
beyond that you're looking at trends
so you can look at general trends of
whether it's going to be you know a
generally warmer or milder winter for
example but then you're looking kind of
more about
the balance of likelihoods when you go
beyond that you can't predict
day by day year by year because there's
so much complexity but what you can
successfully uh
look at is the longer term trends
of warming and general patterns of
rainfall change and actually the
the early climate models that were
produced in the 1960s and early 1970s
they made predictions which have now
been shown to be accurate so it was
predicted in the early 1970s
that by the year 2000 the world would
warm by 0.65 degrees celsius that turned
out to be reasonably accurate the truth
was about half a degree so it was a
slight overestimate but not too bad uh
and the warming has continued since then
so so we're now in a state where we are
able to see that the early predictions
of climate science are broadly coming
true we're now also seeing more extreme
weather of some kinds so more extreme
heat waves uh in some areas more extreme
rainfall
more increased drought in other areas
uh that gets more difficult to tease out
particularly signals but we are seeing
those starting to change now so broadly
speaking
we know that we were saying the right
things 30 or 50 years ago uh but we
still can't really yes predict perfectly
for many years in the future because the
system is so complex and cutting so then
becomes
a task of risk assessment rather than
trying to make perfect predictions you
see
is co2 the
sort of fundamental underpinning or one
of the main pillars of what you guys are
looking at with regards to climate
change
co2 is very important it's not the most
important greenhouse gas in terms of its
effect on the climate at the moment
because the most important gas is water
vapor
and we're not directly changing water
vapor in terms of human activity except
for very small uh
areas where we're irrigating
so we're concerned about co2 because
that's the one that we're increasing the
most in the atmosphere and it stays in
the atmosphere a very long time uh
decades to centuries if you consider
that
if you if you increase the amount of co2
that increase will be there for decades
or centuries
ahead because it doesn't break down
chemically in the atmosphere so that's
why the focus is on um
is on co2 but there's other gases like
methane and nitrous oxide as well also
greenhouse gases that we are increasing
what's happening with water vapor
so water vapor also changes and that
changes in response to climate change
uh so as the world warms a warmer
atmosphere can hold more water so water
vapor can be a feedback mechanism on
climate change so it can it can actually
increase the impact of of co2 and other
greenhouse gases you see so it's like a
catalyst let's say that there is a
warming on the earth that increases the
water vapor which permits more of a
warming
yeah yeah exactly yes yeah interesting
what about the increased greening from
co2 because this is something that i've
heard about that the parts per million
that you can get if you have greenhouses
where farmers and horticulturalists are
growing particular things that they want
their ppm to be through the ceiling and
that we're nowhere near that amount
increased greening presumably would mean
more plants more plants would mean that
they absorb more co2 which would then
bring the co2 level down so talk to me
about how all of that pieces together
yep so that's something which i've
worked on uh myself and i've published
on uh several times and that sort of my
phd was on that exact issue actually so
yes
when you put more co2 in the atmosphere
that enhances photosynthesis the process
through which plants grow
so plants will take up some of the co2
from the atmosphere
through photosynthesis so that's a
negative feedback so actually if that
didn't happen we would have warmed the
earth even more because the c2 wise
would have been even greater than it has
been so we would have seen probably
double the amount of uh uh warming than
we had seen co2 is also taking up in the
ocean to some extent uh as well so that
is extremely important uh process and uh
so it is
part a large part of the reason of why
we're seeing greening of the earth which
you can see from satellite that some
areas of the earth have denser
vegetation cover especially kind of
semi-arid regions where
there's limited water so higher co2
means plants
need less water um so they can they can
green up more there's other reasons for
the greening that we're seeing changing
land use also the warming of the climate
itself in the very cold regions simply
warmer temperatures when you get longer
growing seasons so there's many factors
behind the green but co2
is one of them
the reason that's also important for the
future is we
we don't know for sure whether that will
continue to the same extent in the
future uh
you know from laboratory studies that
this uh the impact of co2 on on
photosynthesis it kind of kind of
flattens off at high levels of co2
but we also know that higher
temperatures as well as leaving a longer
growing season in cold regions that can
have a detrimental effect in hot regions
so the key question is will this
beneficial effect of co2 continue into
the future
we need to do more large-scale
experiments in real ecosystems with high
levels of co2 to really be sure about
that so again it's an open question so
when you're considering risk assessments
you need to account for a range of
possibilities of how co2 will affect
will effect reading in the future
how have you been able to tease apart
the industrial impact on co2 in the
atmosphere
so uh
we know for sure that the uh the co2
rise is entirely man-made because the uh
the amount that we're putting in the
atmosphere from fossil fuel burning is
way more than the amount that we're
seeing uh building up in the atmosphere
uh about double uh in fact so simply by
conservation and mass you know we're
putting 10 billion tons of carbon into
the atmosphere every year from burning
fossil fuels another one or two billion
from deforestation the amount to build
up in the atmosphere he's only
equivalent to about five or so billion
tons of carbon per year so simply by the
by by the arithmetic there uh
we know that what the increase is due to
the
uh
industrial impacts it's been offset by
the natural
uh impacts of uh uptake of co2 by
natural vegetation how do you know that
that wasn't just a trend that was
occurring and that's now been continued
well we we've you can look back uh in in
time over
from getting data from ice cores uh if
you if you drill down into into ice
layers on the layers of ice that have
been built over thousands of years and
examining the bubbles of air trapped in
the ice as the snow fell
and trapped air within it and then
turned to ice
uh you've got a record of the atmosphere
going back thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of years so you
can analyze that and see what's what the
ct concentration was and
before we started burning fossil fuels
in the industrial revolution the co2
levels were
hovering around about 280 past million
for many many thousands of years uh and
they did go up and down in the more
distant past you can infer it from
fossil records it did change naturally
in the past in response to very large
scale changes in global ecosystems but
in a much slower rate than what we've
seen in recent recent decades the rate
of co2 increases just way more than
anything's been seen in the previous uh
paleoclimate record i heard something
about the milankovitch cycle which is
this sort of climate wobbling up and
down in temperature we're going up and
down and this is part of a small uptrend
before we then go further down how much
legitimacy do you see in that
yeah so that
that again that's that's perfectly uh a
good piece of climate science that
uh that colleagues of mine have worked
on for many many decades or more
so the
uh so yeah this the the the ice ages are
generally linked to these milankovic
cycles the change in the earth's orbit
and the
the the tilt of the earth um
so that
that's
yeah an external forcing on the climate
system we we call it so change in the
earth's energy balance or the patterns
of how the energy from the sun is
reaching the earth
occur due to these changes in earth's
orbit and the and the the tilt of the
earth
that can lead these kind of feedback
processes like with the carbon cycle
which mean that yeah as vegetation
changes over the world it can take up
more co2 for some periods or release
more co2 as you come back out of the
cycle and this is all part of our
understanding of how a feedback process
in the climate system so the the reason
that this is important is because that
then lets us see
when we're looking at how we're warming
the worth with earth and other forcings
like human cause increasing co2
how feedbacks may then amplify or dampen
that
in the future so all links together as
our understanding of the climate system
what's the current projections that you
guys have got with regards to
temperature and
co2
i don't know let's say that we don't
make too many changes and kind of things
were to continue as they are at the
moment what happens to temperature in
co2 concentrations
so if we carried on um as as we are we
would we would see global warming of
anywhere between two and uh possibly up
to four degrees celsius by the end of
this century it's very hard to be
precise because we don't know the
strength of all the feedbacks the best
guess is probably somewhere below three
degrees warming by the end of the
century if we carry on uh as we are with
currently implemented policies on energy
and and land use just there richard when
you say um on average when when a
climate scientist says on average an
increase in this
how's that figure worked out is that an
aggregate across all areas around the
globe because presumably
certain areas will increase by more
certain areas will increase by less
how do you come to that figure
yeah exactly so this this is all done uh
with climate models which are
essentially the same models that we use
for the weather forecasts so these are
models uh based on mathematical
equations which represent our
understanding of the physics of the
climate system
uh so
we understand the workings of the
atmosphere pretty well
so we're able to
make these calculations which can
explain past changes in climate and make
projections of the future as i said
earlier you can't make perfect
predictions there's a certain amount of
uncertainty but if you compare
the models with what they've done in the
past and compared with what we've
observed in the past in terms of past
warming you can actually narrow the
uncertainties to some extent so so these
projections i've just talked about are
based on
uh
an assumption of uh carrying on emitting
as we currently are as you pose the
question but also how that plays out in
terms of the response of the climate
system
linked to what we understand from past
changes yeah so we've got this water
vapor as one of the examples you have
this feedback mechanism so you have a
first order effect which is an increase
of co2 then you have a second order
effect which is an increase of water
vapor then a third order effect which is
co2 in response to the water vapor and
so on and so on and yes i mean
that the computers that you've got
running these models must be
pretty big and pretty sophisticated
because you can already begin to see how
when you put that across an entire globe
just how many degrees of separation you
are away from what you're trying to do
in what
80 years time to try and arrive at these
sort of figures
yes yeah i mean so these models are vast
there
is 2 million lines of fortran code we
still use fortran which a lot of
computer scientists
find amusing it's a very old computer
language but it is actually it's a very
well used language in in in climate
science because one of the important
things is
many people work on these models over
years and decades uh so it's got to be
a particular computer language which
which it helps with collaboration it's
going to be very clear and structured so
there's dozens maybe even hundreds of
people have worked on the met office
model uh over the years so so it's two
million lines of fortran which represent
the mathematic mathematical equations
which represent the physics of the
climate system these calculations are
done for ten thousand tens of thousands
of points across the earth's surface and
many many layers in the atmosphere so
yeah huge huge models which take weeks
to actually do the calculations in fact
that's crazy i had heard something
uh to do with where temperatures are
detected temperature changes
how do you ensure that there isn't a um
discrimination with regards to where
temperature changes are measured let's
say that you take them from particular
areas and not from others or areas are
more represented i'm going to guess that
this is something you guys have to
account for as well
yes exactly so uh colleagues of mine uh
in the topics and in other institutions
across the world have done a lot of work
on this um
because
there's
thousands tens of thousands of data
points and weather information taken
across the world every hour probably
even every minute these days actually uh
and
bringing that together is done routinely
for monitoring weather and helping with
weather forecasts
and is now done very systematically
across the world and there's quite high
standards for that if you want to look
at climate change in the past if you go
back a few decades the quality is very
good we've got satellite data as well
which also helps give a big picture but
if you go back you know in the 80s and
70s you've got satellite data if you go
back before that the uh the network of
weather stations across the world is
less systematic
we got measurements taken from aircraft
and ships and weather balloons as well
but once you get back to the start of
the early 20th century you've got much
more sparse data and then beyond that
you're much more limited
and
sometimes in many cases you have to be
very careful whether this data is
reliable especially if weather stations
have have perhaps even shifted uh like a
particular town has moved its weather
station from one side of town to the
other you've got local effects like an
urban area will generate its own
temperature impacts and so on you might
have had a forest cut down not wind that
kind of thing so you have to account for
these by cross-checking uh
the weather stations in in certain areas
uh there's a lot of quality control goes
into that now um and
uh
so it's not it's not a trivial matter
you can't just look at the raw station
data because you will get a very
misleading picture you have to do this
kind of cross-checking uh to make sure
you get a clear and accurate picture of
change over time
what happens if we get to the end of the
century and we're
less than three degrees but more than
two degrees warmer
so uh
i would say we will probably have
initiated uh some uh some severe
long-term sea level rise impacts at the
very least because uh it seems that well
mountain glaciers are already melting
because we've won the world already so
we're already locking ourselves into
uh putting more melt water into the
oceans and therefore more sea level rise
we're seeing seed otherwise happening
already uh we may well have initiated uh
some further long-term uh impacts of uh
melting a part of ice sheets in
greenland uh and antarctica
if we keep warming below three degrees
perhaps we won't er kick off the the
worst of these but i think exceeding two
degrees does risk some major impacts
like that and also we would have changed
where the patterns in many parts of the
world
some of the hotter parts of the world
which are already kind of almost on the
edge
of what humans can live with day to day
we'll be going past areas at past
times of extreme heat stress for humans
and so on so places like the indian
subcontinent parts of africa uh a two
degree world would probably expose about
a billion people uh to extreme heat
stress for more than ten days uh a year
we've calculated so the hotter parts of
the world would be seeing severe impacts
and then we've been seeing impacts on
biodiversity the colder regions of the
world where a lot of the ecosystems and
species of animals and plants are
adapted to
to cold uh temperatures
they won't be seeing the cold
temperatures they're used to so we'll be
seeing massive impacts on biodiversity
and human life there as well actually
in terms of you know ways ways of life
which cultures which are adapted to cold
temperatures you see
what about if we get closer towards four
degrees is there a step change that
occurs there or is it just more of the
same
horizon it it's very hard to say that
where there's any kind of particular
step change you often hear you know uh
about you know critical thresholds and
so on you can't run away
cyclical natures of stuff
yeah so so you you can't put your finger
on any any particular level of global
warming that would that would definitely
uh kick off any kind of uh chain
reaction but the more
warming we put into the system the more
we risk these large scale changes like a
irreversible
uh melting of the greenland ice sheet
for example which would take centuries
to millennia to completely melt away but
you can reach a point to no return with
the greenland ice sheet where as it
melts the surface of the ice sheet comes
down to the warmer temperatures in the
lower atmosphere and that sort of feeds
on itself just explain that to me
so the greenland ice sheet is very thick
it's miles thick
so as the surface of that
melts under higher temperatures the
surface comes down lower into the
atmosphere and the lower part of the
atmosphere is warmer than the higher
atmosphere so you could bring the
surface of the greenland ice sheet into
an area of warmer uh temperatures and
that could mean the warming in the
melting could could feed on itself you
see
so that's one of the irreversible
changes by being high you're actually
protected and refrigerated and you have
a a frozen area which covers over an
area that perhaps would be
even now prone to melting but it's kind
of it's almost protected over the top
yeah yeah
exactly that's right so and there's
other potential kind of tipping points
in the climate system which which
which may exist but we don't know
exactly where so one very famous one uh
is the uh amazon rainforest tipping
point where uh some early models of ours
uh predicted a very severe warming and
drying in the amazon region um most
models don't project such as severe
drying now it has to be said so so
that's actually something of a relief to
some extent however most models do
project something of a drying and
warming in that region and that means
that
the the other impact on the amazon is
from deforestation so the real threat
from uh
to the amazon probably comes from a
combination of deforestation and climate
change so this kind of milder drying of
the amazon that means that any impacts
of deforestation would would be worse uh
because deforesting the the amazon means
that the edges of the forest dry out and
become more susceptible to fire so it's
more complex than simply a
climate-driven die-back that the older
models showed it's more link between
deforestation and climate is the amazon
benefiting from increased greening from
co2 is that helping it to grow back more
quickly
uh large parts of it at the moment yes
some parts of it know some parts of it
are now so
so warm and getting drier and are
becoming impacted by deforestation and
degradation that they're not benefiting
uh but large parts of it are so a key
question for us uh is how long will that
continue in the future uh we we've
recently initiated uh well i say we
colleagues of mine in brazil are setting
up a major experiment in the amazon
rainforest to look at exactly this uh
will the rainforest remain resilient and
will it take take up more co2 as ct
levels uh are increased so that's a big
piece of science that needs to be done
to help us you know narrow down the
incident in our models
talk to me for a second i want to try
and get into the
philosophical underpinning of what
climate
not necessarily climate science but what
um having a climate conscious
worldview is actually trying to achieve
whether or not it's trying to keep the
planet the same whether it's trying to
make it as hospitable for humans as
possible whether it's trying to um keep
a hold of biodiversity whether it's as
my friend and past guest charles
eisenstein said just trying to retain
the beauty of the planet as much as we
can
what do you see as the goal
of
whatever you would refer to climate
conservation perhaps um what what's the
actual outcome that we're aiming for
so i mean that probably comes down to
something of a personal view so i can
only offer my personal view on this
others will have a different different
view but but for me uh
it's uh
from the point of view of humans it's
about making sure that we don't make our
environment uh you know
uncomfortable and therefore and
ultimately impossible for ourselves in
certain places it stands to reason that
we have evolved uh under a certain range
of climates in the past we've adapted
our societies to certain local climates
uh we are actually fairly adaptable
humans live in a wide range of places
across the world uh
so to some extent it's it can be about
keeping the climate what we're used to
in a particular location because we have
we've built cities based on our own
local climates
um
we but but in other cases it's about
making sure that we don't go beyond what
is actually tolerable for people in the
very very hot uh uh parts of the world
where there's an upper limit what we can
cope with as humans or at least what we
can kind of function within so that that
that's part of it it's about making sure
that we don't make things inconvenient
or impossible for ourselves but also i
think there's more of a
you can imagine there's a moral uh
view on on our responsibility to other
species as well other species on the
earth are adapted to certain uh local
climates
we're changing that
uh so a lot of people including myself
would would regard it as unethical to uh
to to make life impossible for for other
species and ecosystems and uh
there is some
beauty in the earth you can appreciate
you know in cold regions glaciers uh we
love a cold i love a cold winter's
morning for example uh
i i do feel sad that the the the cold
weather we used to see the 1980s happens
much less frequently now although it's
inconvenient but i did like a nice cold
winter you know so uh so those kind of
changes they can it's an emotional
aspect to that as well as cultural
aspects as but as well as also you know
human
practical and survival aspects and
survival aspects for the species so a
whole range of things yeah it's an
interesting one i definitely see as a
steward of the earth i think that as the
only ones aboard spaceship earth that
aren't just cargo but we're crew as well
we have
some sort of moral obligation i think to
you know
act well as guardians of of the other
creatures and the diversity that we've
kind of inherited um
i wonder whether
i wonder how much there is a price that
needs to be paid
if you could almost see it as a
balancing act between
having an advanced civilization that is
able to bring people out of poverty that
is able to raise living standards that
is able to access degrees of health and
wellness and flourishing and economic
value and so on and so forth
whether
well presumably i'll put it to you is
there a sacrifice that needs to be made
in order for us to get that presumably
by trying to restrict carbon emissions
what we're aiming to do is
have our cake and eat it too it's we
want to be able to live in a
technologically advanced world but we
also don't want these negative
externalities that we have from
uh the climate being wrecked
yeah and this this is why it gets so
controversial because people have
different views about where this balance
uh should lie uh so yes we we want to uh
have you know a good and happy and
fulfilling and comfortable life for
everybody on earth uh and uh
that requires
uh yeah a certain level of living
standards which which we have
historically relied on fossil fuels
and the use of the land to achieve but
now we're recognizing that the way we've
done that in the past is ultimately not
sustainable in the long term
but at the same time you can't rip that
away immediately because we rely on it
so much so the phrase just transition
gets used so it's about how
where
people
individuals societies uh you know towns
and cities and even countries that rely
on the old way of doing things
how they can transition to a more
sustainable way of doing things without
disadvantaging people so if you say for
example this whole communities rely on
coal mining and if we just shut down
coal mining has happened in the uk in
the 80s it has devastating effects on
the local community so you have to find
ways to get get through that and make
sure that people have other other
sources of employment and you don't just
rip the heart out of a community and
replace it with nothing else so it's not
a true trivial problem to deal with i
learned that
cheap energy is one of the best ways to
raise people in developing countries out
of poverty and that fossil fuels are one
of the best ways to get them that is
there a tension between trying to reduce
fossil fuel use and also still trying to
get developing countries up to an
acceptable living standard
so there is attention there and the
other tension of course is the the other
effects of of fossil fuels such as local
air pollution and so on uh so again from
the in the
in the uk we experienced in this you
know in the 50s and 60s incredible uh
air pollution incidents my dad uh who
was from the black country would
remember horrendous smogs uh where it
was just desperately unhealthy to be
outside uh and
a lot of people died of respiratory
related problems and so on uh so that
was all to do with local air pollution
the uk is sort of you know
by getting out of so much coal burning
has reduced those problems those
problems still exist in other parts of
the world as well um so yes there is
this tension uh as you said but there's
also the other effects of uh air quality
and so on you need to take into account
as well yeah that's what we talk about
kind of co-benefits is actually the
phrases gets used as a code there's
other benefits of reducing fossil fuel
use beyond the climate impact like
improving equality and so on yeah but
then there would also be kind of co
costs which is
the reduction of access to energy it's
it's
one of the things that strikes me is
that we're kind of fortunate that the
planet is as small as it is i know the
earth's massive i know that it's big but
we can fly around it in the space of 24
hours pretty much now if you're on the
right plane and
if the planet was even bigger you would
have so many different interest groups
so many different nation states i mean
it's already hard to coordinate stuff at
the moment with different actors and
different agendas and so on but let's
say that
earth was able to sustain itself the way
that it was but it was maybe twice as
big which would be an awful lot more
land mass an awful lot more humans an
awful lot more nation-states even wider
varieties in terms of the
climates and the countries and so on and
so forth um
trying to get trying to find a middle
ground where you have
every different nation's interests
aligned you know we've recently had cop
26 in glasgow and you know for all that
countries can go there and say that we
want to do this each country has its own
different agenda about where it is what
its desires are for growth for economic
policy for everything so yeah i think um
we're probably quite fortunate that we
have
although it's massive as smaller sample
size of planet to work with
yeah that's got a very interesting point
which i i'd never heard before yeah so
yeah i think things could be even worse
is what you what you're saying it could
be even more complex yeah you you could
need 50 million lines of code in order
to be able to work out what's going on
yeah yeah yeah that's an interesting one
but the complexity of the of the issue
and you know the negotiations that cop
and so on it it is a huge uh a huge
problem because uh yeah
governments have responsibilities to
their own people and economies and so on
and and yes they they want to on the one
hand keep protect their populations from
the worst impacts of climate change but
they don't want to
just radically change everything uh
especially uh the developing world which
is seeing that we'll be in the developed
world of benefit of all this stuff
historically
they are
they want they want some support from us
uh at least making making this
transition is just transition i was
talking about earlier well yeah because
they're still playing catch up to try
and get their living standards to where
they see the west already benefiting
from it whether that be because we got
there first or we have slightly
preferable climates or whatever economic
policies
and
because of the current state of
the climate you could see it as these
bourgeois western bastards coming in and
telling you that
wagging their finger at you and saying
no no no you need to be along with us
and he said well
we're not in the same boat here we have
completely different living standards
and economic structure than you do so
making developing countries
sing to the same hymn sheet as a
developed country is going to cause even
more disparity
yeah and i think that's exactly at the
heart of a lot of the negotiations that
the negotiations were happening in the
last couple of weeks uh in glasgow cop
26 and the other aspect of course is the
fact that uh
these countries along with everywhere
else are living with the effects of
climate change that are already
happening so they've already warmed the
world by over degrees celsius we're
already seeing some changes in extreme
weather we're already seeing an increase
in sea levels in some cases so the more
vulnerable parts of the world which
which uh happen to be uh often the
countries which have been contributed
less to the issue are now asking for
support in dealing with that putting in
place adaptation measures there's a
strong argument comes from some quarters
oh we should just adapt our way out of
climate change or at least adapt our way
through it
but you need to actually put things in
place to do that adaptation and again
it's the same countries that that need
support on
uh getting away from fossil fuels and
deforestation that need support in
adaptation uh because they happen to be
the hotter parts of the world and
perhaps low-lying countries and so on so
again this is another big issue that was
addressed at that cop 26 but not fully
resolved
did you
what was your what's your synopsis what
was your sort of summary of that i mean
i'm i'm gonna guess this is kind of like
you've got a
uh illustration of glastonbury behind
you cop 26 must be a little bit like the
glastonbury for uh for climate
scientists but just maybe a little bit
less fun um
what's your how did you feel that that
went based on sort of what you know and
what you can tell us
well the uh the yeah
that's another very good analogy
actually the these climate conferences
are huge there's so many things going on
uh the at the heart of it yeah the
pyramid stage if you if you like is in
negotiations that's what everyone the
rest of the world sees uh where this the
countries are negotiating about which
what emissions they will
they will cut uh and how and will they
support each other in adaptation then
around that the rest of the festival the
other stages in the festival there's
also this many different even more
delegates are having conversations
amongst themselves linking to the
negotiations
updating uh ourselves on each other's
work on climate science what this means
for policy hearing from policymakers
about what they need so it's a big kind
of meeting of mines around this
negotiations
so there's two different levels to it
the outcome of the negotiations
uh i would probably say uh it's not as
good as we would have hoped uh well not
as good as we needed to keep ourselves
on track to meet the paris agreement
targets of limiting warming well below
two degrees it didn't achieve that yet
but it was a good step along the way a
lot of positivity things did happen
there were some good agreements on
reducing deforestation
actually specifically identifying coal
as an issue that needs to be addressed
there was an aim to get countries to
commit to getting out of coal completely
that wasn't achieved but there was a
commitment to reduce coal use there were
other things on adaptation again not
going as far as was hoped but
uh more than was feared so it's a
halfway house really
beyond that the uh the i think
having this the the opportunity of
networking and sharing the information
sharing the science um
that was reasonably positive i think
there's a good shared understanding
building as well which i think that will
help inform the next cop in a year's
time where more needs to be done on the
negotiations is it annual
it is yes there's one every year except
for last year uh when there wasn't one
because of
the pandemic so the one from last year
glasgow was supposed to happen last year
basically yeah
has there ever been one which has
attracted as much media attention as the
one that we've just seen because i you
could have told me that this happened
once every five years
and i would have believed you
yeah so this was this was particularly
prominent uh especially in the uk uh
because we were the host nation um but
because also it was it's been five years
since the the last prominent one which
was in paris so the paris agreement
which i mentioned a few minutes ago was
at a previous cop which was uh very
prominent because that was the first
time where there was a natural agreement
between all countries uh to take action
on climate change that had never been
achieved before in previous cops so that
was very prominent and also
the the ambition
which had been uh
talked about in previous cops before
paris was to limit warming to two
degrees global warming the ambition
became
to try to limit that to 1.5 degrees that
was another key thing in paris so the
paris one was as probably as prominent
or almost as prominent as as as the
glasgow one but they're not always as
prominent as this is that's for sure
yeah what's the enforcement mechanism if
some nation state doesn't abide by what
they're doing if china just
tells you what you want to hear but then
decides to just crack on
spunking loads of co2 out
so that so uh
the the the commitments can be monitored
there's processes in place to sort of
check on how emissions are actually uh
progressing that can be uh that that can
be
uh
uh there can be orders here that uh the
deforestation can be monitored by
satellites so the data is there you can
measure how much the co2 is
building up in the atmosphere you can
see where
where emissions are are are coming from
um but in terms of actual enforcement
like with any international
agreements uh
it's actually fundamentally it's down to
almost peer pressure between the
countries uh essentially uh you know
there's no international law as such
it's basically countries uh gentlemen's
agreement
exactly yes yeah so it's so that so like
like any of these things it's about the
you know the
the community
uh you know
encouraging itself and policing itself
really there's another thing to consider
uh i wanted to start talking about china
in a second but
we're at least not in
open
disputes with most of the countries on
the planet can you imagine how much more
difficult it would be if we were seeing
some of the
uh nation divides
uh in terms of territories from the
1900s world war one world war ii cold
war lack of communication between
different countries
and we had
some climate challenges to overcome
because you would there's no way that
you're getting coordination in fact it's
perhaps because of the tragedy of the
commons it's maybe even
in the interests of particular countries
that might be able to weather the storm
of climate change better to be able to
utilize that uh
industrial machinery to just try and get
themselves as far ahead because they're
still in conflict with whoever else it
might be kind of fortunate that we're
not at war at the moment
yes it is
i mean although another aspect of this
is the climate change being an extra
stress on on certain countries and so on
so again this is one of the particularly
controversial issues it's about the role
of uh climate change and international
security and wars and so on you could
you can't really pin any specific wars
on climate change as
such but but uh
you can start to see that um it doesn't
help when you get more extreme weather
in a region which is already uh under
tension uh then an additional natural
disaster so there's quite failures and
that kind of thing it's it's not helping
at all you know so it's a further thing
to bear in mind in the future i sort of
start saying that china contributes 30
percent of the entire world co2 do you
know how true that is
uh
in terms of emissions it's it's the
largest um uh emitter uh so
they they they do have a huge huge
population and they have uh you know
ramp took up their energy uh production
in the last 20 years uh as they've gone
undergone a rapid development so uh so
yes
china is the biggest uh emitter uh as a
country it's not the biggest emitter per
person uh because they have a very large
uh population the emissions per person
are still smaller than the usa for
example oh that's interesting uh yeah
but in terms of the actual emissions
they're they're they're the largest yeah
yeah that's interesting so i had um a
conversation the other day which really
opened my eyes to this so i i'm quite
concerned about china um i i think that
sort of globally it's it's a threat that
we need to be taking far more seriously
and i started talking about this
particular statistic that it's the
largest single contributor of co2 on the
planet and one of the person i was
speaking to
richard decided to say well
yeah that may be true but you have to
also think that one of the benefits that
we've seen in somewhere like the uk is
that we've outsourced a lot of our
industrial production to china so the
fact that you can then point to china
and say look at all of the stuff that
you're throwing out into the atmosphere
is and we can stand on a high horse and
say look at how green we are it's
facilitated by the fact that a lot of
our production has now been outsourced
there that we're getting electronics and
machine parts and so on and so forth
from that country
yeah that's exactly right so when you're
uh looking at a country's claims on how
well it's reduced its own emissions so
for the uk for example uh monitors our
own emissions we were the first country
to put in place
the climate change act so legal
obligation on the government uh to
reduce emissions
uh and the climate change committee this
independent advisory body will track
the uk's progress uh against its
commitments and you have to be very
clear about whether the emissions
reductions being quoted are the total
emissions that the nation is responsible
for including what's called offshoring
yeah what we've been
uh what we're buying from other
countries elsewhere in the world which
includes china but other places as well
uh are you including that oh are you
just not talking about domestic
emissions what we're admitting locally
uh so you're absolutely right that you
have to look at the bigger picture we're
responsible ultimately for uh emissions
elsewhere in the world what we consume
as well as what we create yeah yeah yeah
that's um yeah yeah i've found i mean
understanding stuff like that i find
very interesting i think that you know
having that in the back of your mind
when
i can still be concerned about china but
having that as a little bit of a um a
caveat was was interesting does it does
it annoy you that climate science
sometimes gets
forgotten or tarnished due to
crazy stunts and protests that grab
attention
um yeah that's an interesting one it can
um
so i i i think that some things can be
unhelpful if they're yeah annoying a lot
of the uh yeah the population when
people are uh
you know particularly if they're like
obstructing public transport or
something i personally think that is
sending out the wrong message you know i
i'm an advocate of public transport and
and cycling and that kind of thing
um so when some people have used public
transport to get their message across uh
i think that was the wrong target but
self-defense uh
yeah yeah the uh uh on the other hand uh
i can see how
keeping the issue in the news uh
is a useful thing uh as well uh
the
i mean
we're going to break the law you know
when people are perhaps
even potentially endangering other
people then i get you know i'm not happy
with that um so the
you know if you if if you go as far as
yeah something's kind of some things can
be counter productive so you have to be
quite quite careful about what what what
you're doing i i think it's uh it's a
very difficult area i would much rather
uh
that
say that the the media new media for
example um
gave prominence to to to climate science
uh in a in an unbiased way uh one of the
protests last year was particularly
targeting certain uh sections of the
media wasn't it and the reasons that the
protesters came from that was that they
still saw that this uh in certain
sections of media that they were saying
didn't give a true picture um
i would while the media
covered climate change in a in a good
unbiased fact-based way so that people
then didn't have to feel they had to
take this kind of radical action yeah i
um i read an article a while ago by
scott alexander from slate star codex
it's called the toxoplasma of rage it's
very interesting and he talks about the
fact that
activists or anybody that's trying to
push forward a a narrative or an agenda
they have a balancing act to make that
the more outlandish and gregarious
stunts that they can do they do capture
more attention but inevitably they
polarize opinion a lot more too
uh on the flip side of that the stunts
which are perhaps much more persuasive
and well-meaning and
rational
don't capture as much attention but
don't cause the polarity and also don't
um
that it's easy to get people on site so
there is a
payoff that you need to decide between
exposure and impact or exposure and
persuasion and
from my
side based on what i see i think
it feels to me like climate activism is
sacrificing a lot of persuasion for
impact and i think that that being drawn
back now you may be right maybe that
could be assisted through other channels
but from your
uh
seats in the middle of the climate
debate what would you do
if you were someone whose job it was to
try and improve the messaging uh you
know it's not good enough to just put
excel spreadsheets up like it needs to
be engaging there has to be a reason for
people to take care but also this
this undertone that you because you
drive a car to work you should feel bad
about what you're doing i don't think
that that i don't think shaming people
into compliance is the right way to go
about it either so what would you what
your thoughts on the messaging at the
moment and moving forward
yeah i i i i agree
nobody likes to be told what to do
and nobody likes to be ashamed about
what they what they're doing um
i much prefer things which are you know
more positive and and creative and you
and you can find things which are
uh attention grabbing and creating more
positive an example here locally uh some
local activists um last year
uh
hires a load of road cones and they put
in an unofficial cycle path uh on one of
the main roads in exeter that goes to
the hospital
so they just put this psychopath and it
was completely unauthorized and then
they sort of sat by and they and they
watched and they filmed uh people using
it to see whether first of all to see
people would use it and they did see
that hospital staff doctors and nurses
who cycled to work were using this this
psychopath um
half a day later that the council took
it away because it wasn't authorized
but i think i i quite like that as a
more kind of constructive thing it
didn't do anybody any harm uh and it
illustrated the fact that the psychopath
there would be really useful um so i
would like to see more of that kind of
thing yeah more more positive
imaginative and creative things that uh
that really
are helpful uh rather than rather than
negative that's my personal view
one of the things that i definitely
notice in myself you brought up the
cycle lane so in gosforth which is where
i live in newcastle
the uh two-lane high street sorry the
two per side so a four-lane high street
was reduced down to a two-lane high
street to
accommodate a cycle lane
the traffic on that now is is disgusting
it's absolutely awful anybody that tries
to get from the great great north roads
down into newcastle knows what i'm
talking about
um
there's something
there's something about that
that is a little bit uncomfortable
because
you observe the inconvenience that you
suffer from a front row seat you know
that if you're stuck
between 3 p.m and 5 30 p.m or any time
during the morning on that road that
it's going to take you 10 minutes to do
a mile and that's going to annoy you and
you knew you'd also remember the time
not long ago when it didn't cause that
long
i think
creating a grand narrative creating a
more cohesive understanding around why
these measures get put in place so let's
say that adding a cycle lane helps to
reduce carbon emissions by
whatever percent
i don't know that
i don't know that i just see
what broadly to me looks like a mostly
unused cycle lane and a ton of traffic
that's
tailed back so
what i think is missing
first off i would suggest to climate
activists to
dial back the amount of shame that gets
put under people i don't think that
that's an effective strategy at all i
think it just makes people kind of
resent whatever it is that you're doing
but
a broader
understanding of the direction that
we're trying to move toward and how
individual actions contribute to that i
think that that's important because it
connects the sacrifice that you make if
someone said to me if i was able to feel
good
about the fact that i know i need to set
off 10 minutes early to get to town but
that by me setting off 10 minutes
earlier to get to town i'm actually
helping
in a way
to reduce down carbon emissions because
we have increased other people's ability
to cycle to work then i'm like oh okay i
kind of feel i kind of feel good about
this and or at least it dampens down the
inconvenience do you understand what i
mean
yes yeah and i i think uh
uh also uh
we could encourage people to think a
little bit uh
outside their own kind of narrow
uh view you know i don't mean it's a
negative way but sometimes people don't
realize that they could do things
differently uh sometimes they genuinely
can't uh sometimes they could do if
given a bit of help so again using the
cycle names one as an example um there's
a lot of people that have no choice but
to use the car that's that's for sure i
mean here in exeter we're a small town a
small city but with a rural area around
it it's very hard to get anywhere in the
rural area without a car
within the city um it's actually
much easier than a lot of people think
to get around by bike for example i i
haven't had a car for two years uh in
that first period
i was actually quite surprised about how
easy it was to live without a car i just
use my bike and
public transport
and trains
some people i think a lot of people
could do more like that i recognize a
lot of people could not do that but
those who have no choice
their lives would be easier if those who
who do have a choice could make a
different choice but often those people
could only make that choice if they're
helped along the way by having yes safe
cycling routes and that kind of thing so
it's not all down to individual people
it's about helping the changing the
system to help people make these make
these choices
how much do individuals decisions
about what they do you know one person
remembering to turn the lights off or
putting the the lights on a timer or
switching to a hybrid car or an electric
vehicle
how much is that going to make an impact
even if you start to scale that on mass
across an entire population and how much
of it is from other things that are more
out of our control so perhaps things
that are
in industry business controlled by the
governments
uh transportation owned by companies and
stuff like that as opposed to
individuals
so the uh
yeah
the small actions like turn the lights
off and you'll change your low energy
light bulbs and that kind of thing yeah
have have have a small impact it is
system level change like entirely
different energy sources
so not having uh coal fired power
stations having instead
renewables or nuclear or whatever so
that's a sort of system level change
which uh
would need to be
people would would obviously have to
buy into that as as consumers and uh
uh and it needs to be separate set up in
a way which is not disadvantaging uh
people so you kind of
yeah it's seeing yourself as part of the
bigger uh bigger picture picture really
yeah
what's your thoughts on nuclear energy
personally speaking
i
would be surprised if we could
achieve the targets without nuclear
energy that's a personal view not as an
expert
you know i'm a climate modeler uh this
is just from you know me seeing the
debates from from where from where i sit
i see arguments uh
we say it can't be done without nuclear
energy
so you know i'm speaking as a non-expert
here i'd be surprised if we could do it
without without nuclear energy i think
the problem is so severe that we need to
throw everything at it basically we
can't rule anything out that's my view
why do you think it is that there is a
quite a big swath of climate um
activists people who
dislike nuclear energy
i think that that links to the the the
the
the origins of the green movement
uh
who traditionally uh were sort of
suspicious of any any kind of technology
uh and of course you know there have
been horrendous nuclear accidents in in
the past of course uh the
technology is very different now and uh
the uh new nuclear
power stations are are being designed
and built to a yeah much much higher
standard and uh the risk assessments are
done to account account for climate
change as well yeah carrying a very high
temperatures uh
nuclear plants that are being created
now are being future-proofed against
potential higher global temperatures
exactly uh exactly yes yeah and that's
so sophisticated um i had alex epstein
on the show quite a while ago the moral
case for fossil fuels so he's a
philosopher that's talking about and um
i i don't understand enough about the
impact of different types of fuels to be
able to kind of dig into his data but
what i did take away from it was uh
a surprise
at how much most
climate activist groups seem to be very
averse to nuclear energy which is
you know
aside from
a couple of very big accidents which
occurred on version 0.1
uh reactors and plants that were very
unsafe um
it it surprises me that that isn't just
what everybody is throwing
throwing their efforts at um
i mean it it it is true that the
high-level waste is a long-term problem
uh that you kind of yeah you'll be
queening that to future generations but
it's a relatively small amount that uh
you know in the grand scheme of things
but but it does exist so
part of the concern is about what we do
with this stuff which is going to be
around for um
for thousands of years
as well as the obvious
concern
based on past experience
um
past accidents but again this is again
why it's such a controversial topic and
you get very very polarized views on it
richard betts ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with what
you do why should they go
uh you can follow me on twitter richard
abets on twitter uh you can also uh
look at what the
meta office and the university of exeter
are putting out i work at both of these
these places you could you could look at
the the technical report of the climate
change risk assessment which i i led
which is published this year
uh so look that up it's a uk climate
risk uh it's a website uh so you can
look there for some of my latest work
but uh yeah i'm active on social media
so i'm always happy to have a
conversation about this i just talk to
anybody who's interested in climate
change so happy to have a discussion
thanks for today mate
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace